I want to spend the rest of the time
talking about a whole bunch of gay stuff
because I mentioned on the show a week
and we've done five of these here yeah I
think this is our fifth episode since
we've been with Aurra I've only watched
once mentioned anything about being gay
I don't I don't make it an issue unless
it's relevant quite a straight gay it is
what it is I mean believe me I'm gay I'm
married you don't mean I'm married to
dude pretty gay
okay but I don't know I actually you
know okay so you are selling out I know
you're selling out selling out to the
hetero pixel institutions yes yes we'll
get to those de gay yeah I know you're
better you married my god alright
anything more awful so before we do that
portion of this it's hilarious the the
liberal here married one and the
conservative one is the one railing
against marriage it's fastened I just
think it's sad that you know I want
heterosexuals to come back to
institution of marriage I want them to
realize that it's a good thing I want
them to become more socially
conservative in that regard I don't want
gay people being growing up back so
we're just gonna go all in on this I'll
reverse my question so go go all right
I don't think being gay is particularly
fun and I wouldn't choose it for any of
my children for example I think Sally
Kohn who said that they like they're so
that she'd like to have a gay child I
thought it was deplorable and sadistic
and incredibly selfish so meaning what
if satisfy yourself has come to a place
really what she said was if she could if
she said what she said was if she could
pick she'd rather have a gay kid and I
thought that was a deplorable thing to
say because what what's it is ridiculous
Charlie might you may have child's life
so much more miserable but but it's
getting easier every day what don't you
think that when how will you
oh gee you don't ask again all right
well you really own a propagator yeah
terrible failure is a game si lady but
point B I see it's a lot it's a lot
easier for you than it was for a 30-year
old gay man ten years ago and it's gonna
be way show better but so there is the
normalcy that no no no what you're
you're confusing two different things
there's a sort of practical um ease with
which a gay person can go through life
because there is no longer the
entrenched homophobia if you like in
certain wider society the
the the fact that gay people can have a
relationship and live together and
nobody really cares and I don't think
anybody cares anymore
what I've said that for a long time I'm
so sick of talking about it which is why
I don't all I wanted was equally just
want to be treated as I didn't know I
think I better than anybody I think gay
people getting married and in
relationships is a shame because I quite
like the dissident a naughty sort of
aspect of gay life and I think that it's
you know part of my gay privilege to be
able to tumble out of a nightclub at
3:00 a.m. with you know doorman on my
arm and you know hopped off my face but
you do that while still no having other
people like you people like you getting
married getting a dog living in a little
house you know a dog yet um you know
horrible horrible no self-respecting
gays home enough to feed something like
that no I mean I don't know what you're
doing with your time I really what do
you keep coming home come at sue tonight
darling who's cooking tonight I should I
do all right then well he looks he's all
right yet awful awful awful yeah but you
shouldn't be another house long enough
so you gonna keep that alive but really
do you really believe that I get it I
get what you're doing here on the snark
level I get it no why do you think
there's some value in this because I
think that and I think it's because gay
look gay homosexuality is a dissident
aberrant sexuality I mean that in a
morally neutral sense you just mean it
to the other
I don't gather no I don't mean that um
you know using the term like correctly
but I'm what do you mean no I
didn't say apart I said look I'm let's
let's set the religion stuff aside
because they were going to get into a
rabbit hole but let's just say you know
how they try to you is not the norm it
is an aberrant sexuality that mother
nature may do for a variety of reasons
right there's some evidence that people
with higher IQs are more likely to
engage in different sexual appetites
that was one of the reasons why gay
people have disproportionately higher
IQs and one of the reasons I think for
example that gays should get back in the
closet because we're making society
stupid because gay people are breeding
anymore whereas previously you could you
would have a marriage with a woman and
you would have a couple of kids and gay
men were still in the gene pool right
yeah now they've taken themselves out
they don't have their own biological
children anymore like you've got your
sort of two to five percent of the
smartest men in population on breeding
any what people keep saying us are we
gonna have kids and if they I don't know
but we're gonna keep it if you do you
should have your own biological children
because you're smarter than most people
you're the lamb did you catch that we're
gonna keep trying oh and see you're so
into your thing there no I thought we
were being serious all right all right
um yeah no okay yeah all right um it
doesn't work when you yeah I I just you
know it's kind of a silly thing but it's
certainly true the the sort of average
of intelligence is sort of chugging
outwards slowly but it is definitely
being if five to ten percent
you know of two to five percent rather
you know of the smartest people in
society aren't breeding anymore so
anyway I think that's a silly but III
didn't know it's a shame when as a gay
is one of those people that Mother
Nature has selected to be different and
to test stuff out and to push the
boundaries we'll come on to in a minute
in respect to free speech I think that
you sort of buy into precisely the sort
of the sort of socially conservative
institutions which I love and I
recognize the building blocks of society
I recognise databases available Society
writes on personalization as aroma
session has a homosexual knots case it
shouldn't have them as a homosexual you
should recognize that your your
evolutionary function is to experiment
with different models of things right
and one of the ways in which gay culture
and society has done that is the sort of
sex mad hedonism that I enjoy that I
think sorry that you did you don't have
anymore because you have this horrible
mother people I've well I've done I've
got wait hold up but you're you're
combining eighteen different things here
so first off the I sense that a lot of
what you're saying is you just you long
for the day probably when you were 22
and you were out every night and doing
all kinds of drugs and having all kinds
and you all right so would last week
right long for that day and a lot of a
lot of mainstream gay look I live in
West Hollywood I see what I think case
of a kind no ring so I think gay people
have become very very dull what is that
it's a shame isn't that no it's not good
because what says we are ugly quality no
why would we want to be equal we were
already superior why would we want to go
down to equality it's absurd to me we
already know we gay people and web
mother nature makes our mistakes and
makes her great discoveries of all the
great all the gay geniuses in history
you know whether it's curing or you know
Abe Lincoln reportedly or you know all
the other Roman emperors you know look
at what Mother Nature does with these
aberrant special people at the top end
of the intelligence and sort of
dissident so you know to scale those
those those what Steve Jobs are call the
crazy ones right and this is why the
tech and gaming industries are
disproportionately gay and trans because
it's those special people that have
brains wired slightly differently from
others who can make those great leaps
yeah who can you know consider problems
differently who are generally more
creative and more what I'm with you on
that music whirring with you I as Y as a
member of the game master race would you
want to slump down to the level of
heterosexuality because you should have
the option oh yes it is I'm not telling
you what to do if you want the option
what I'm telling you is you made the
wrong choice
okay so you don't think that a lot of
these people that are doing all the
things that look I did them you know you
all of those things sex drugs all that I
did all that you know ii mean i don't i
look back on much of it very fondly
actually people people people call me a
traitor to my sexuality your traits
sexuality you know at least I'm stay
silent I don't think my agent would
allow me to tell you why cop too but um
you know why don't you Trey so the
things that you I think you're looking
at this in this nostalgic way of fun
right there was the center but it's
assuming but wouldn't you trade some of
that look when you think about all the
people that are having promiscuous sex
anymore cause all that no no those
numbers gonna directly go down because I
tell you I don't care about sexually
choices is easier so who gives a
I don't care about that what I care
about is the fact that there's a serious
point here it's not just the fun living
those fun lifestyles and I mentioned
Steve Jobs early only said that much
moment many of his innovations come from
the factory took LSD right gay people
have a license to experiment a license
to explore it's one of the reasons why
gay culture which is so so to do with
exploring boundaries pushing the limits
of acceptable discourse and speech and
thought right those are all the things
that I love that I well no you don't
because you slid sit into you know I'm
honoring all
slid into boring domesticity it's
precisely with those put those horizon
broadening experiences which you have
given up as a as a you know as a
housewife or a house husband or whatever
I think two weeks are having home-cooked
meals and I'm watching that for two
weeks of my back wheels I want to enjoy
myself I want to kill myself people call
me a trace in my sexuality please no
look I think that the gay people are one
of the groups in which Mother Nature one
of the groups mother nature is given
license to go wild and that's why so
many great artists and inventors and
authors and all over been gay lesbian
whatever because we have a unique
license and unique opportunity and
insight into the fringes into the that
put that edge of culture that makes
stuff interesting we have an ability to
push further than ordinary people can we
can say things they can't say for
example I can go on TV and say an all
manner of outrageous things about
feminism only because I'm armed sexual
right do not let me ask you thing do you
think I could get away with those same
things because obviously we have a
little different effect people always
say to me you don't seem gay which I
know you wouldn't Barry get you I mean
it's kind of may say it as a compliment
kind of my thing right people know that
I'm gonna do this sort of social justice
proof it's very difficult to argue that
a flamboyant homosexual who never shuts
up about her about you know black
boyfriends is in any way bigoted right
so it gives me I've established myself
in the public mind the public
imagination in a way that you haven't so
a lot of that ironically that's what
this is about you like while you're in
some ways rail against these people that
want to be protected like the feminists
or whatever you do like how do I know
you
I enjoy using their weapons against them
and I'm perfectly haven't used a weapon
against I wish I didn't have to yeah I'm
glad you in mother I would much of it no
I don't want to be trolling people for
my whole life of course I don't you know
but I would actually rather with a case
that everybody had free open frank
discussion but at the media as currently
constituted if you want to push forward
the discussion outside the ROMs of
academia in the public square talking to
ordinary people for example I wrote for
a publication is there a mid brow
mid-market publication for everyone the
sort of digital media equipment the
tabloid newspaper I will talk to
everybody and to push debate forward in
those environments you do have to play
by the rules and some of those rules are
based on identity politics which I think
are absurd and obscene stupid yeah but I
will certainly play along with them if
it helps because it's so long as as
aggressives and feminists refused to
have a debate on the basis of the facts
and insist on having a debate in our the
basis of identity and skin color instead
fine I can beat them in that too you
know I'm happy to beat you on any
playing field on any battlefield you
choose they've chosen identity politics
I can beat them there if they ever want
to come to the table and debate properly
I'll be tonight so that I think I think
you're on to saying interesting there
there you'll use their weapons I don't
like their weapons and your I don't like
that you're using their way I danced
them I did I think in a cheeky sense
where where you know that your there's a
wink to what you know you know and let
anybody reads my Twitter feed knows that
it's you know I know exactly what's up I
know what's going on but they still lose
anyway um
so part of the reason why I wanted to do
this is because I do find that again
while we come from different we
literally come from different countries
but come from different political parts
of this but you really at least an
American media only get one gay only one
gay gets out there and it's the Bravo
gay that's either on TV because they're
a fashionista or they're a sidekick to
one of the housewives or they're somehow
involved in pop culture or something
like that or every now and again someone
can break free like an Anderson Cooper
but then sort of have to be completely
asexual right never talk about their
life and I think this is sort of
interesting because we both break that
that paradigm yes and I think it's
partly because we are cultural
libertarians I would certainly describe
myself as one I think you probably I
hope you'd agree with that I think that
we are those sorts of insurgent
countercultural new media personalities
we exist you may not like to hear this
but we exist on a spectrum with people
like Trump and Ann Coulter more probably
I'm a lot more on the serious end of it
simply in tapping into ordinary people's
frustrations with the limits and
absurdities of you know what they see on
broadcast television and what they read
in the newspapers there is an
alternative way of having a discussion
which is more honest and more more I
mean this kind of thing could not happen
on broadcast television for example and
that's a problem that's a problem for
the media that's why one of the reasons
they're exactly one of the reasons
everybody hates them you know and I
think we both are taking advantage of
that fact as far as the sexuality goes
what I find interesting about you know a
liberal and conservative homosexual
agreeing on so much about
authoritarianism is that
well from from my point of view of
homosexuality is where we experiment and
you know drag-queen culture for example
is all about pushing the boundaries of
acceptable language and thought we see
the threats to freedom of speech for
example we see the authoritarian threat
over coming over the horizon a long time
before anybody else and we're in a
position to warn other people about it
and there's a very serious point about
this which is not just that you know
transsexuals hate drag queens which is
one front in this sort of progressive
fracturing because drag queens loves you
know this sort of no-holds-barred Joan
Rivers style comedy which you know is
the essence of of gay identities of
pushing those boundaries and
experimentation in transgender people
who have got to fallen into this
authoritarian mode hate that kind of
stuff it's not just it's not just about
that it's not about our community
fracturing if you like but it's also
that we see some of the serious
consequences to these infringement saan
on culture because of course politics is
downstream from culture and what becomes
not unacceptable saying politics becomes
unacceptable to that so becomes
unacceptable in culture becomes an
exception politics and we recognize and
we see the warning signs here so we're
sort of the canary in the coalmine yes I
think that's true this I think is I
think gamers did this to unit I think
gamers in gays have very very similarly
because gamers are marginalized people
in many cases disproportionately ethnic
minority disportionateately transgender
in my experience often marginalized
personalities often people who are
retreating into video games may because
they have great social skills often very
bright brilliant kind of autistic you
know methodical very male brilliant
minds and very funny in but sometimes in
have a social skills and in that way
they're quite similar to gates because
they had a occupy fairly unique position
in the in the social hierarchy of
society and I think gamers did in their
own industry what gay people ought to be
doing in public life which is precisely
that being a canary in the coal miners
saying for example that the sort of
nannying hectoring language policing
that's happening in progressive media
today is a problem it's a problem
because I mean the first signs are the
policing of gay sexuality there's a
piece in in The Daily Beast I think that
said that men who express a racial
preference on their Grindr profile are
racist
now it's obviously an absurd thing to
say it's completely stupid and it was
some idiot middle-class white woman who
decided that she was gonna police gay
sexuality today just as we you know just
as we were getting to a position of
Tolerance suddenly that people you know
someone coming out coming over the
horizon to police gay sexuality it's
happening for two reasons
one gay men have high status in society
they've become very Molly cold very
celebrated in the media so they've sort
of acquired a kind of privilege and when
the left you know the left is constantly
engaged in the business of ranking
people according to their oppression
rating and gay men don't score very well
on in those games because you know you
think we look good we have money and we
know we've basically become another kind
of white man for a lot of these right so
you would say that basically the
progressives or as I'm now calling them
the regressives basically you're done
with the gays yes yes Davis says exactly
the world game since they were like
we're gonna we're all for it they're
done you know you know they've got your
gay marriage and now you're going to
find increasingly that they come off to
you and they're going to come ask to you
because you're being too racially
insensitive they're going to come after
you because use the wrong pronouns
they're going to come after you absurdly
and brilliantly for misogyny you know I
mean if you would people make arguments
to me sometimes and they say and it's
it's not as credible in your case but I
can understand how they can strut the
argument as bonkers as is they make
arguments that basically boil down to
you're such a misogynist you went gay
you know if you hate you hate women so
much I can tell why you are you sleep
with men now it happens to be that I do
think there's a large element of choice
in my sexual orientation although that
goes entirely against a progressive
consensus will do a whole thing on that
another show yeah but it's an
extraordinary thing that they now coming
off the gay people for being
misogynistic for being racist all sorts
you're no longer of any use to your own
side right they have used you they have
put a wedding ring on your finger
they have domesticated you like they
would a dog like you did your dog they
have put you in they have they have made
sure you got the right politics that you
say the right things in public they have
domesticated and delineated you know the
sort of useful liberal gay idiots and
put them all in little ghettos in cities
like the Castro and West Hollywood and
now you are the product and the and the
chattel of the liberal right so I know
both into I you you don't mean me
specific so I do mean use but you know
that I stand for interval this no but
you know I stand against it
the sort of gay marriages away button
trolling gay pee right but I suspect
that along the way if you met the right
person you would want to marry that
person for all the bhramari know I might
move them into the West Wing but I
wouldn't marry them okay so we do have
to wrap up here any when we could have
done three hours here and we'll do this
again for sure but the stress point yeah
I want to get to this this piece that
has been the through line to everything
we've been discussing here this this
authoritarian left this this regressive
piece where there have no problem
relentlessly I look I could use the
example of the gay rights groups here in
America you know glad or the HRC who
will relent who will attack the pizza
makers relentlessly but will say nothing
when gays are thrown off the roof in
Iran in Iran right and or recently wrong
kind of gays speak out you know the only
cut there is there is a source of person
in America today sorry to drop you
there's a sort of person in America
today who is just a homosexual
discriminated against its gay
conservatives it was much more difficult
to admit you're a gay conservative than
judgment you're gay you're gay you get
slaps on the back you get applause you
get all how's me prove you know if all
of the sick all of the social signaling
about being homosexual is positive with
one exception but if you're a
conservative other gays the gay
establishment and Britain's Fidelis
wrote an amazing essay about this in out
magazine it's called something like in
the reign of the magical girls everybody
should read it you know it explains how
the gay establishment which is basically
now done with gays and it's a
self-perpetuating
set of institutions to push leftist
socialist principles got nothing to a
gay rights anymore
will treat you as what you would call an
Uncle Tom in race terms you know I have
never in my career as a purposeful
provocateur I don't play the victim on
Twitter or in my columns because you
know I think you should if you should
take as well as you give a rule a rule
all gay people learn quite early in life
but you think miss that one thing I did
that go there there yeah I got it took
this I was shifting yeah it's a rule we
learn quietly I know it's you know I
think it should build it's better
tickets give it and I never play the
victim but I've never had so much really
poisonous vitriolic nastiness as from
other gays who think that my politics
are wrong and it's Werfel wouldn't the
ultimate success here be
I've been arguing for a while now that
by gay marriage being legal now in
America in the long term you actually
help the Republicans because this was
such an idiotic issue for so many people
to have to vote on is the idea that I
had to vote on not that not that it was
the deciding factor but it was I had to
vote on whether I could get married it's
a nonsensical and and painful
and pathetic waste to vote so I actually
think ultimately this may turn into a
net win for the Republicans because I'm
not sure days I'm not sure that's the
case
everything about this and I call it
minority wars the way in which you know
if the last ten years was about setting
men and women against each other the
next 10 years about all sons of other
minorities I mean you know in the
Hispanic population in the US who are
not encumbered by the guilt of slavery
become the the demographic majority
you're going to see some pretty brutal
policing in places like Ferguson you
know because they don't have the same
kind of white middle-class guilt about
about you know black lives matter they
weren't you know Hispanic mayor's in
barely a few generations are not going
to be paying multi-million dollar
settlements to black families they're
going to be sending police in with guns
you know it's it's there's all sorts of
horrible things on the horizon and it's
driven by the identity politics of the
left which are crumbling but not fast
enough my serious point about all of
this is that cultural libertarianism
which I keep banging on about which i
think is always sort of what we've been
talking about but yeah it's a word that
I'm glad is catching on with people can
we just I know you named a few of them
but it from the article that I saw on
Breitbart I thought it was a brilliant
article will link to it it wasn't
running by the way but yeah but can we
just name a couple of these people I
know you named a few of those so I mean
but Bill Maher was including Bill Nye
talking Bill Maher's in there Chris Rock
is in there even though he does rely a
lot on his on his blackness as a source
of his comedy he Nunnally is somebody
for example he's spoken up about the
political correctness at colleges on
college campuses and says you won't
perform to students anymore because
they're too touchy right I think he
understands this I think Eli Roth the
the horror director Adam Baldwin who
serves a sort of fantasy actor and he's
in love with the gamergate stuff and
then you've got the way these things
normally work is you've got sort of
Vanguard of hellraisers like me and
Katie Hopkins in the UK and kalter
perhaps here now that all those those
three happened to be right-wing but I
don't think it's I don't think you can
play well that I don't think you can
place people in the political spectrum
and that's why I want you to mention
some of the names because what I liked
about
article is that these people were from
all over them I think the hellraisers
tend to be conservative today simply
because the establishment is liberal
right I think that's why then further
behind that you've got the more
politically ambiguous figures like
Christina Hoff Sommers at the American
Enterprise Institute or Cathy young
feminist journalist who aren't so easy
to place politically Cathy's definitely
a liberal I think Christina is
Christina's registered Democrat in fact
you know but who nonetheless recognize
the excesses and in the wake of the
chaos created by the hellraisers that
people like me kind of you know winding
people up and and being you know sort of
viciously teasing people I consider to
be you know dangerous and damaging and I
got it I believe half of it but you're
throwing bombs no no I believe all of it
I believe all of it but perfectly you're
happy to accept that I will say at the
most provocative way possible because I
think the only responsible the only
appropriate response to outraged culture
has to be outrageous you know if you're
going to tell me that I can't make jokes
about about skin color I will come back
at you you know with with ten puns about
me being obsessed with black penises or
whatever you know for the record you
brought a six foot six black porn star
ID till I hired it I hired a black porn
star just because it would annoy the
right people to be my bodyguard because
I get bit I get death and bomb threats
everywhere I go I don't make a big
sundance about except to laugh at how
stupid is when I don't believe any
feminist bomb threats ever going to be
credible they can't even tie their own
shoelaces together let alone wire a
detonator I'm not worried about getting
blown up by feminists what I what I am
worried about is the chilling effect
that they have on free speech and might
get back to the point yeah gay people I
think and I think this is what something
in which you and I United having
privileged access if you like to you
know the the limits of acceptable speech
and discourse that is that great that
great drag queen joke you know but which
I love from from Britain which get
always gets shocks and a national
newspaper wouldn't let me publish which
was she comes on stage and she says you
like my new hair it's called the Whitney
black and died in the bath
and people get a little horrified by
though mmm you know Gabe gave you will
live and love though you know that sort
of stuff
and we see before everybody else you
know what the serious consequences of
this is a chilling effect on free speech
can be and those consequences are as you
know the sum total of human
knowledge and whatever you know surgeons
because of Jay s mill classical liberal
is unconscionable - modern feminism they
don't believe some of the central tenets
of you know on which pure British
society was built this is dangerous
stuff it's dangerous stuff because of
what's happening in our universities - I
mean just look at the sorts of you know
look at the the feminist hegemony you
know Women's Studies departments that
you know that run rampant on campuses at
Yale I don't know if this is true and
I'm not
miss remembering this but I saw
something you know DeRay McKesson the
black lives matters guy is teaching a
course at Yale and defensive looting you
know all this kind of stuff this is a
weird crazy I saw a tweet about that I
don't know if it's video we'll see but
the the Women's Studies stuff at um you
know in many decent universities is
scary it you know it's denying human
knowledge is making people invent this
stuff makes it to government in this
regard it's not you're not just talking
about women's studies though because
this is coming from all over this like
Berkeley protesting Bill Maher coming as
it's ggressive ism generally I have I've
just seen I'm supposed to speak at USC
tomorrow night and I've just seen you
know this horrendous blog post from
somebody who says that I'm a sort of a
misogynistic hate speech merchant
because I made a joke about I don't know
what it was it's probably some joke like
you know feminist Barbies just come out
when you pull the cord it says math is
hard let's lie about rape you know at
some some joke like that um you know and
they and they paint me out some sort of
misogynistic harasser their words people
I think that to take away and that
that's really where I sort of wanted to
end this with you because yeah we can
everything I've tried to do with the
show so far is show that you could
disagree with people and we can we can
go back and argue the tenants of
feminism or whether I think you're right
or wrong about men being oppressed or
the gay marriage thing all those things
but but allow the conversation to happen
and I think that's happening and that's
what the cultural libertarians they were
talking about our trying to do
you